hindert uns die arbeit an einem guten
leben nein sagt der philosoph thomas
maczek für ihn sind arbeit und leben
keine verschiedenen dinge
ich freue mich mit ihm über den sinn den
wert und die potenziale der arbeit sowie
über das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
zu sprechen
packen wir es an warum arbeiten sie
eigentlich arbeit ist für mich das beste
mittel und meine eigenen fähigkeiten zu
entfalten in erster linie um besser zu
werden und natürlich aber auch spaß spaß
an der arbeit ist natürlich etwas sehr
schönes sie bezeichnen die grenze
zwischen leben und arbeit die man zieht
so allgemein als bullshit warum wir
kennen auch von der vorstellung aus dass
es sozusagen zwei welten gibt er hat der
eine welt die welt der lästige
notwendigkeit dass es die welt der
arbeit das die welt und der werden nicht
die sind die wir wirklich sein könnten
und die andere welt hingegen die welt
der freizeit das wären und die welt in
der wir uns wahrhaft selbst entfalten
können und diese trennung diesen
dualismus inhalte für falsch und für
irreführend sondern ich glaube viel mehr
an arbeit ist selbstverständlich und
teile des lebens und ich glaube dass
arbeit auch bei trägt zum guten zu einem
gelingenden leben
das wef in davos hat sich dieses jahr
auch dieses themas angenommen und hat
die vierte industrielle revolution
analysiert und gesagt dass ihnen diese
grenzen dass das was wir historisch oder
traditionell als arbeit bezeichnen sich
in andere dimensionen aufgelöst dass wir
in einer epoche sind wo es neue formen
der existenz sowieso gibt hier setzten
sie ja auch gewissermaßen an
ich glaube wir stehen das natürlich vor
einem großen wandel nicht also durch die
digitale revolution fallen dinge bedingt
stellt sich für viele die frage was wird
nun aus der arbeit
wird die arbeit aufhören erleben wir das
ende der arbeit werden in zukunft da
sind auch höhere geistige tätigkeiten
und durch computerprogramme ersetzt
werden
das gab es so die situation in der wir
uns gerade befinden und die natürlich
viele menschen auch sorgen bereitet aber
an solche wandel der arbeit immer wieder
in der geschichte gegeben
das ist an sich nichts neues jetzt sind
sie philosophie also eine relative halb
modische ein altmodischer job beschrieb
wenn man denn so sagen kann und sie sind
chefredakteur eines eines philosophie
magazins das heißt also relativ
privilegiert und behandeln die arbeit
ganz grundsätzlich können sie aus dieser
privilegierten war das wirklich etwas
sagen über die zukunft über die wandel
die die brüche in dieser situation sehr
wichtig also die frage bekommt natürlich
oft gestellt also erstmal habe ich
natürlich auch andere jobs gemacht und
in meinem leben schon auch dinge gemacht
die vielleicht jetzt nicht so angenehm
waren wird am beispiel also das
schlimmste job denn jemals gemacht habe
er war in meiner studentenzeit als
ferialpraktikanten sichere ich heiße
also praktikant das ist jemand also den
sommermonaten haben sie ein bisschen
geld hinzuverdient als schüler oder
student und das war ein job in einer
wiener krankenkasse aber meine tätigkeit
dahin bestand ein ganzes monat lang
jeden tag rezept durch zu sehen ob sich
ein bestimmter buchstabe am rechten
unteren eck befindet also das war eine
form von arbeit
die würde ich heute noch als entfremdet
bezeichnen und das war sicherlich die
schlimmste arbeite jemals gemacht habe
das heißt aus dieser erfahrung heraus
schöpfen sie auch heute noch wenn sie
sich auch ein bisschen haut natürlich
nicht gerade ich sage nicht als vaculik
aber dass sie ein permanent arbeiter
sind gewisse absolute wobei ja immer
wieder erlebt dass menschen natürlich
meine
form von arbeit verdeckter von einer
philosophie zeitschrift falsch
einschätzen nicht dass es gibt welche
fehler die vorstellung haben
der philosoph machte ganzen tag nichts
anderes als im wald herum zu spazieren
und über dinge nachzudenken
nein so ist es nicht nur das auch mein
job hat viele seiten die nicht unbedingt
so angenehm sind also auch ich muss ganz
viele e mails beantworten muss ganz
viele dinge tun die viele andere
menschen auch tun müssen und haben sie
sich auch mit dem plan b als einander
gesetzt das vielleicht eine philosophie
zeitschrift ein auslaufmodell ist dass
es in ein paar jahren gar nicht mehr so
gibt das ist die rolle eines
chefredakteurs nicht mehr gibt dass wir
keine philosophen mehr brauchen weil es
ersetzt werden durch einen intelligenten
roboter also wie bei hoher ruft aber
diese frage immer wieder mal gestellt
ich glaube aber dass wir gerade das
gegenteil erleben und ich glaube dass
gerade in der heutigen zeit das internet
in der zeit kurze aufmerksamkeitsspanne
und vor schnelligkeit
das ist ein gewissen bedarf gibt an
reflexion und philosophischer reflexion
moran philosophischer selbstreflexion
und dafür ist print nach wie vor ein
wunderbares medium auch einander
gewisser weise ein medium der
entschleunigung um solche
reflexionsprozess anzustoßen
aber das ist ja schon ein bisschen das
sagen sie ja selbst auch sehr früh in
ihrem buch dass wir ein sehr paradoxes
verhältnis zur arbeit haben also
einerseits jetzt eben auch als
philosophie sagen sich ich bin nicht der
der täglich durch den wald spaziert und
die gedanken suche auf der anderen seite
liefern sie muße potenzial für ihre
leserschaft und sind da in einen
gewissen clinch drehen weil eigentlich
müssten sie ja auch etwas von der muse
verstehen und nicht wie sie das im buch
natürlich auch auch als als ein bisschen
soll seine journalistische at t ist
haben wir brauchen nicht weniger arbeit
wir brauchen mehr arbeit aber dafür
bessere arbeiten also für mich ist musik
auch ein bestandteil von guter arbeit
also wir haben es daran gewöhnt so
denken dass das gegen gesetze seien
nicht also dass muse im gegensatz zur
arbeitszeit
aber ich sehe das ganz anders ich glaube
gute arbeit so wie ich sie mir vorstelle
so wie ich sie mir wünsche müsste eben
auch phasen der muse beinhalten und es
sehr nicht warum das nicht möglich sein
können in der kulturgeschichte dabei das
würde mich sehr interessieren also wie
ließ diese arbeit war zustande gekommen
dass alles was ihr arbeit nehmen also
schon die die wort herkunft des begriffs
arbeit verhasste ansicht nichts gut das
nicht also schon das germanische wort
arbeit bedeutet ja immer strapaze
bedeutet mühsal bedeutete war also
arbeit war lange zeit mit körperlicher
anstrengung verbunden das darf man in
allen diskussionen und überarbeiten nie
vergessen und arbeit stand auch lange
zeit einem sehr schlechten ruf versorgte
verachtung der arbeit gerade auch bei
den philosophen oder eine lange
tradition
wenn sie denken sein ticket griechenland
bei den griechen galt arbeiter ist eine
unwürdige tätigkeit das eine tätigkeit
deren menschen in moralischer und in
geistiger hinsicht disqualifiziert in
unfähig macht für das gute leben sind 33
monja der glückseligkeit nicht also für
aristoteles war ein mensch der arbeiten
musste das ist natürlich alles klar für
ein erster linie in griechenland ein
banause einfach dem einfach die zeit und
die muse verehrte für alle höheren
tätigkeiten für politik für kunst und
natürlich für philosophische
kontemplation
also das hat sich nun geändert
vor allen dingen durch das christentum
das christentum hat dann die arbeit neu
definiert wenn man so will also einen
auftrag des schöpfergottes fortzusetzen
nicht also bei paulus heißt das dann
wer nicht arbeiten will der soll auch
nicht essen nicht dann etwas was über im
übrigen die sowjetunion in ihre
verfassung aufgenommen hat später also
das verhältnis zur arbeit hat sich immer
wieder gewandert und haben jetzt
großen sprung zu machen nicht also
entscheidend war natürlich dann der
beginn des kapitalismus der beginn der
lohnarbeit im modernen sinne wie wir sie
heute kennen diese lange zeit nicht gab
nicht nur so lange zeit war ja arbeit
nicht getrennt von anderen teilen des
lebens das er zuerst mit dem
kapitalismus geändert da ist dann unser
modernes da hat sich unsere moderne form
von arbeit letztlich erst heraus
gebildet was als also ein bisschen
wurmfortsatz des müßiggangs übrig bleibt
ist vielleicht der sonntag absolut nicht
also der sonntag ist natürlich wissen
der tag an dem gott roth mit seinem
schöpfungs werk und absolut darum ist
natürlich auch immer diskussionen ob man
nun am sonntag arbeiten sollte dann
nicht besonders heikel
aus meiner sicht ist eine gute tradition
zumindest aus diesen einen tag in der
woche frei zu haben um sie mit anderen
dingen zu beschäftigen
die frage sei wenn wir den sonntag haben
wenn wir die frage nach weniger arbeit
geht uns die arbeit aus alle diese
verschiedenen komplexen faktoren
einbeziehen und wir sagen vielleicht
müssten wir tatsächlich ein bisschen
weniger arbeiten um uns auch anderen
dingen widmen zu können wenn uns
vielleicht die jobs dann irgendwann mal
wegfallen und sowie das wef das
definiert hat dann könnte man sagt man
kann den samstag noch dazu nehmen und
man kann den freitag natürlich selbst
selbstverständlich sehr gut dazu nehmen
weil viele büroangestellte auch
nachmittags um zwei schon weg sind und
dann wäre eigentlich der donnerstag der
freitag der zukunft und so könnte man in
einer sehr angenehmen salamitaktik quasi
die ausdehnung des wochenendes auf die
arbeitswelt ein bisschen daraufhin
studien für viele eine schöne
wunschvorstellung
es gibt gerade im amerikanischen
bestseller der wir auch bei uns
erschienen ist in dem sogar tief vier
stunden woche propagiert werden also die
vorstellung vier stunden pro woche seien
genug das halte ich für unrealistisch
ein bisschen aber grundsätzlich weniger
zu arbeiten also die wochenarbeitszeit
so zu reduzieren halte nach wie vor für
für für einen vorschlag über die man
diskutieren kann und sollte
jetzt ist es natürlich sagen dass ein
bisschen angetönt in dieser kultur
geschichte der arbeit drin dieses
ambivalente verhältnis auch ein bisschen
dieses misstrauen gegenüber dem
nichtstun und so kann es sein dass
natürlich in unserer gesellschaft nichts
tun und müßiggang schon eine art von
passiver kapitalismuskritik ist oder wie
es ein bisschen zu unterdrücken
viele glauben dass ich persönlich bin
ein bisschen skeptisch nicht also diese
form von kapitalismus kritik hat eine
lange tradition
das beginnt schon bei einem mann wie
poller falsch dem schwiegersohn im
übrigen von karl marx der also ein recht
auf faulheit propagiert hat ein recht
auf müse gang der meinung war aber sei
eine seltsame sucht die bekämpft werden
müsse
das setzt sich fort bis hin in die 60er
jahre 68 wenn während des sogenannten
situation ist hängt mit dem slogan
davaria also arbeiten arbeiten sie nie
also die vorstellung arbeitsverweigerung
als kritik am kapitalismus also form von
widerstand gegen kapitalismus hat eine
lange tradition
ich glaube es ist die falsche art von
widerstand meines erachtens
sollten wir versuchen der arbeit besser
zu machen
die arbeit zu verändern aber nicht uns
der arbeit zu verweigern
aber dass man wenn man die welt ein
bisschen auf teile sind die herren und
sind die knechte und man denkt wenn ein
arbeiter ein armer mensch arbeit faul
ist dann ist das etwas problematisches
wenn ein reicher privilegierter mensch
nicht arbeitet und privatisiert ist das
ein privileg und es gibt dann sehr wohl
alternativen einer sinnvollen
beschäftigung sich dem tag interessant
zu gestalten wenn man es sich leisten
kann
ja also es gibt sicherlich viele
möglichkeiten am tag interessant zu
gestalten ohne zu arbeiten
vielleicht was man die die welt der
reichen betrifft also wir haben
natürlich hohe ungleichheit ja und es
ist ein problem und großes problem des
kapitalismus dass einige wenige menschen
offensichtlicher sie leisten können
nicht zu arbeiten während das fehle
nicht können
ja ich glaube halt das arbeit ganz
wesentliche besonderheit hat ja arbeit
schafft gründe
ja und zwar gründe die von unseren
wünschen unabhängig sind also dass wir
beide hier sitzen zum beispiel hängt
damit zusammen dass wir arbeiten ja und
dass wir hier etwas tun so wenn wir uns
verabredet haben so funktioniert aber
das mit verpflichtungen verbunden
und das ist eben etwas was sie nicht
haben wenn sie nicht arbeiten also das
heißt arbeit als gesellschafts kit das
die ganze maschinerie zusammenhält die
identifikation
es ist ein wichtiger teil der teilnahme
des individuums andere gesellschaft wie
wichtig sind dann zum beispiel
fragestellungen dass wir haben große
flüchtlingsströme die in unsere länder
kommen ins zentraleuropa die arbeit für
flüchtlinge zum beispiel ich glaube
arbeit ist deshalb wichtig weil sie
menschen identität vermittelt weil sie
anerkennung vermittelt über dinge wie
erfahrung vermittelt und vieles mehr
also weil sie mit anderen worten gewisse
innere güter hat innere werte die für
menschen wichtig sind für gutes leben
wichtig sind und daher glaube ich dass
zentrale aufgabe in der bewältigung der
flüchtlingsfrage schlicht darin besteht
die menschen in arbeit zu bringen
also ich glaube nicht dass wir die
flüchtlingsfrage
allein dadurch lösen dass wir den
menschen die zu uns kommen die
europäischen werte beibringen sondern
ich glaube es wird darum gehen sie in
arbeit zu bringen weil arbeit eben wie
auch viele viele studien zeigen ein sehr
gutes wenn ich das beste mittel zur
integration von menschen in unserer
gesellschaft ist in der schweizer ist
nicht deutschland vermutlich auch aber
gibt es im strafvollzug die sogenannte
arbeitspflichten also dass wenn man im
gefängnis ist ich hab mir das immer
vorgestellt dass man dann endlich muss
er hat da irgendwie james joyce zu lesen
dass das aber nicht sinken sondern dass
man zur arbeit angehalten wird um eben
die integration nach dem strafvollzug zu
erleichtern
also zwänge sich immer ein bisschen
problematisch
aber es ist ganz klar wie vor hinter
gemeinten nicht arbeite das mit
verpflichtungen verbunden
arbeitsstruktur meine erfahrung ist auch
in ganz persönlichen umfeld bei menschen
die durchaus gut verdienen die also
keine finanziellen schwierigkeiten haben
aber wenn plötzlich die arbeit wegfällt
dann geraten sind ganz große
existenzielle schwierigkeiten nicht weil
sie kein geld mehr haben sondern weil
sie plötzlich nicht mehr so recht wissen
was sie tun sollen
wie sie ihren tag gestalten sollen usw
und man sieht es nicht unterschätzen
also viele studien über arbeitslose auch
die berühmte studie über die
arbeitslosen von mal hinten und 30er
jahren zeigen dass er deutlich das
problem von menschen die keine arbeit
haben ist meist nicht so sehr dass sie
kein geld haben sondern dass eine neben
wie vor meinte die gründe fehlen morgen
aufzustehen ja bestimmte dinge zu tun
hat daher ist es im prinzip schon
sinnvoll wenn menschen in der haft zur
vorbereitung auf die wieder
integrationen ins normale leben arbeiten
und nicht nur hinter in der zelle sitzen
und liegestütze mobilisieren wenn sie
jetzt sich vorstellen wir haben also
eine einen großen umbruch der vor uns
stetigen mit dieser vierten
industriellen revolution oder sie der
wir bereits schon stecken vielleicht
seit der jahrtausendwende
und wenn wir sagen wir brauchen also
tatsächlich ein neues verhältnis zur
arbeit weil arbeit auch und arbeit und
leben diese schnittstellen zwischen
realer welt virtueller welt biologischer
welt dass ich das alles neu mischen wird
neu setzen wird und das ja auch ein
neues arbeitsverhältnis haben müssen da
können wir natürlich nicht mehr mit
studien feldstudien aus den dreißiger
jahren operieren wo die menschen
vielleicht ganz anders konditioniert
waren zur arbeit hin fabrikarbeiter
waren mit einer anderen identität als
wir sie heute haben
und das heißt dass wir auch ein neues
verhältnis natürlich zum nichtstun oder
zum anderes tun entwickeln müssen und da
ist sind stichworte partizipation oder
eben arbeite nicht direkt als arbeit als
lohnarbeit sich als weist vielleicht das
stichwort freiwilligenarbeit fürsorge
also es ist ganz klar nicht also
lohnarbeit ist für mich aber nur eine
form von arbeit also ich glaube dass
alle tätigkeiten die mit verpflichtungen
verbunden sind
dazu gehört kann durchaus auch
freiwilligenarbeit
letztlich formen von arbeit sind die wir
auch anerkennen sollten als arbeit
das problem ist dass das system dann
lohnt wenn wir es kennen hat natürlich
eine lange geschichte aber in einer
gewissen weise ist es auch ein bewährtes
system ja
es leidet so viele darunter aber im
grunde genommen hat sich das system als
solches ganz gut bewährt und wenn wir
also neue formen von arbeit oder
tätigkeit von freiwilligenarbeit
ausprobieren wollen wofür ich sehr bin
dann muss man sie eben es ja genau
überlegen unter welchen bedingungen das
den staat hinzu kann wie wir zum
beispiel solche formen von arbeit dann
ebenso absichern dass menschen eben auch
unter umständen davon leben können
also das ist aber nur wie soll ich sagen
eben das geld verdienen ist ein zwitter
oder ein intensiv um zu arbeiten das
anders die wertschätzung als ein
immaterieller werte und heißt es dass
viele bereiche der freiwilligenarbeit
diesen diesen standard die
identifikation nicht so bieten können
dass man mit stolz sagt ich pflege meine
pflegebedürftige mutter
ich glaube durchaus dass solche formen
von tätigkeit in der hohe
identifikationsmöglichkeiten auch
schaffen
also ich glaube es wird darum gehen in
zukunft die arbeit neu zu definieren
also wir müssen wegkommen von dem
verständnis arbeit ist gleich lohnarbeit
ist gleich lohnarbeit im
kapitalistischen system und alles andere
ist nicht arbeit und ich glaube wir
können arbeit auch um definieren
das braucht eine gesellschaftliche
diskussion ja aber wir können arbeit
wenn sie so wollen unser verständnis von
arbeit neu erfinden
also dass arbeit für viele
gleichzusetzen ist mit leonard dass es
in keiner weise natur gegeben
das ist eine art wie wir arbeit ebenso
hier
aber wir könnten sie auch ganz anders
sehen und ich bin sehr für diese
diskussion zu führen in zukunft und das
wird auch glaube ich
notwendig seien diese diskussion zu
führen gerade wenn während die große
aufgabe denke die hat war mit der pflege
von angehörigen auf die gesellschaft
zukommen wird in den nächsten jahren ja
oder bei uns in der schweiz diskussion
über das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
und sagt also man kann eine art von
boden setzen wo die lohnarbeit
relativiert wird dadurch dass man ein
grundeinkommen hat und kann sich dann
eben anderen funktionen bieten
beim grundeinkommen ist meine position
ein bisschen zwiespältig einerseits kann
ich das sehr gut nachvollziehen und es
wird die idee sehr sympathisch dass wir
menschen bevor er von der notwendigkeit
der arbeit dass wir wahlfreiheit
schaffen dass wir mehr autonomie
schaffen
auf der anderen seite aber ich glaube
ich eben das arbeit einem inneren werte
und lehrt hat für ein gelingendes leben
und insofern bin ich hier ein bisschen
gespalten also für mich stellen sie vor
allen dingen zwei fragen das eines eine
ökonomische frage die sich letztlich
darum dreht wie viele menschen werden
nun dass kunden kommen in anspruch
nehmen wird überhaupt noch jemand
arbeiten und es ist ganz klar wenn
niemand mehr arbeitet dann kann das
grundeinkommen nicht funktionieren dass
zwei hätte das zweite ist eine frage der
gerechtigkeit
also ist es wirklich gerecht wenn sie
ein grundeinkommen beziehen
und ich arbeite und ich damit sozusagen
indirekt ein grundeinkommen finanzieren
das haben wir so fragen auf die gar
keine eindeutige antwort habe findet die
diskussion sehr sehr wichtig und
spannend und ich glaube wir werden
wahrscheinlich gar nicht herumkommen das
grundeinkommen da oder dort einmal
auszuprobieren wobei es ja dafür bin
dass in einer sehr vorsichtigen form zu
tun
weil das grundeinkommen eben eine art
von wette ist also wir wissen nicht wie
die menschen darauf reagieren also es
kann sein also die wette ist wir haben
zwei formen das eine ist das vertrauen
in die menschen dass sie selbst
initiativ weiterarbeiten oder das andere
ist wie es wir haben angst davor dass
eben dann niemand mehr arbeiten will und
da sind die zwei misstrauen vertrauen in
die menschheit quasi ganz genau das ist
das problem
die befürworter des grundeinkommens
sagen mit sehr guten gründen und
argumenten wie finde dass wenn ein
grundeinkommen haben dann sind die
menschen nicht mehr gezwungen jeden job
anzunehmen sondern dann wären sie nur
mehr wirklich gute jobs annehmen
diese auch gerne und mit leidenschaft
machen
ich habe für dieses für dieses argument
großer sympathie die gefahr die ich halt
sehr ist wenn wir uns das grundeinkommen
nicht genau überlegen dass wir uns
möglicherweise eine neue form von
massenarbeitslosigkeit schaffen
die eben nicht mehr arbeitslosigkeit ist
sondern eben die gruppe der
grundeinkommens empfänger und es ist
kein zufall dass er nicht vergessen dass
das grundeinkommen ja nicht bloß eine
linke utopie ist das ist ja auch sondern
das grundeinkommen wurde immer wieder
auch von neoliberalen propagiert wir von
den berühmten neoliberalen ökonomen
milton friedman weil man eben dachte
dass das grundeinkommen eben eine gute
maßnahme sei um kosten des sozialstaates
zu sparen beispielsweise und das ein
grundeinkommen deshalb gut sein weil es
eben nicht den marktmechanismen
eingreift also das muss denke ich auch
klar sein wenn wir diese diskussion über
das grundeinkommen führen
es gibt da unterschiedliche positionen
auch mit ganz unterschiedlichen
interessen
ich möchte noch einmal auf die qualität
arbeit als auf die gute arbeit müsse sie
beschreiben zurück kommen und sagen also
dass wir das schreiben sie auch noch nie
so viel gute arbeit gehabt haben wir
heute dass ich vielleicht einfach unser
verhältnis zur arbeit gesagt hat dass
wir ein bisschen verwöhnt wurden in den
in den trend glorie lösung das was
nachher passiert ist aber dass sie auch
sagen man ist ein bisschen selber schuld
wenn man unglücklich ist in seinem job
und da hat sich mir natürlich schon auch
die frage gestellt es gibt wir können
sagen wir privilegierten sind ein
bisschen selber schuld aber was ist mit
jemanden der an der kasse arbeitet in
einem beim grossverteiler oder am
fließband arbeitet da ist die
selbstentfaltung und die dieser
spielraum sein arbeitsplatz und seine
arbeit zu gestalten doch sehr begrenzt
das stimmt also
der spielraum ist wahrscheinlich
begrenzt da ist der spieler den wir
haben
auf der anderen seite denke ich aber
schon und da wäre eine rechtsliberale
auffassung denke ich dass wir menschen
nicht ganz aus dieser selbst
verantwortung entlassen können also aus
meiner sicht ist schlechter aber da so
arbeite keine inneren güter vermittelt
wie vorhin gesagt habe die nicht zu
einem guten leben beiträgt letzten endes
wenn sie so wollen eine art von
zeitverschwendung eine art von lebens
verschwendung die ganz furchtbar finden
und ich finde schon dass menschen auch
die verantwortung haben sie für sich
selbst zu überlegen ist dieser job den
ich hier mache tatsächlich gut für mein
leben trägt zu einem guten leben für
mich bei oder nicht
und wenn sie der meinung sind dass das
nicht der fall ist dann denke ich schon
dass jeder von uns sehen auch überlegen
sollte etwas anderes zu machen
ich habe dieses antreten wenn sie an der
kasse arbeiten nur godín sie den hin
nachher gehen sie einfach in eine andere
kasse
also ich habe selbst schon beispiele
erlebt muss ich sagen ja von menschen
die genau in dieser situation waren
nicht unbedingt als an der
supermarktkasse aber auch an einem job
der jetzt sagen wir mal vielleicht jetzt
nicht so befriedigend ist die jahrelang
in dem job geblieben sind und ganz
vertagt worden
und wir dachten sie hätten keine
alternative und irgendwann sich dann
doch entschlossen haben was anderes zu
machen und in den fällen die ich kenne
jedenfalls haben es die menschen dann
auch nicht bereit diese entscheidung zu
treffen und ich glaube das gilt
letzten endes auch bis zum gewissen grad
für die supermarkt kassieren
sie haben in ihrem buch zitieren sie
eine eine umfrage statistiken aber das
sind schon 2004 glaube ich so schon ein
bisschen
vergangenheit schon fast in der dynamik
der der prozesse in der die arbeit
stecken wo sie beschreiben dass dieses
dieses ausbrechen aus der aus der
arbeits zwanghaften arbeit dass die
menschen wenn sie im lotto gewinnen
würden also diese berühmte geschichte
der zehn millionen im lotto würden
trotzdem 15 prozent nur aufführung zu
arbeiten also das würde ja ein bisschen
darauf hinweisen dass wir das vertrauen
haben könnten in die menschen dass sie
doch weiterarbeiten aber eben dann
vielleicht eine andere arbeit eine
arbeit eine soziale arbeit eine kreative
arbeit aufnehmen würden
das stimmt also besonders schön wenn er
die geschichte von einem lottogewinner
hat er sogar seinen gewinn erst später
abgeholt hat mit der begründung man muss
jetzt noch er muss noch zwei hände
arbeiten also diese fälle gibt und die
finde ich sehr interessant ja ich bin
mir noch nicht sicher welche schlüsse
wird drauf sie daraus ziehen können
auf die auf dem auf die einführungen das
grund eines grundeinkommens das in serie
ganz andere eine ganz andere situation
aber ich gebe ihnen insofern recht ich
glaube man sollte das grundeinkommen
ich mag das ja nicht so sehr es wegen
dem grundeinkommen zu unseren zusagen
wie könnte interesse sinnvolles leben
ein gutes leben umgeleitet werden von
dieser fokussierung auf die arbeit im
klassischen sinn hin zur kreativen
arbeit wo dann die kreative die
kreativwirtschaft auch so ein bisschen
wie die avantgarde ist an der man sich
orientiert ja ich bin ein bisschen
skeptisch nicht es gibt die hoffnung ja
schon sehr lange dass menschen wenn sie
nicht arbeiten müssen dann wären sie
kreativ dann wird man sich sozialen
tätigkeiten dann kümmern sie sich um
ihre nachbarn
dann treiben sie kunst und so weiter das
eine ganz alte vorstellung die wenn sie
so wollen es oft bis auf marx zurückgeht
ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch ob sie
menschen wenn sie nicht mehr arbeiten
müssen und tatsächlich dann so verhalten
ich hoffe sehr dass es tun
aber das ist ja von daher von der vorhin
gesprochen hatte
also das ist hat auch natürlich mit
dieser utopie zu zu und der gesellschaft
utopie dieser situation ist wie sie
angesprochen haben die iphone karte der
kunst die immer schon damit geliebäugelt
hat natürlich die mauer zwischen arbeit
und leben einzubrechen vielleicht
einfach von der anderen seite her eben
aus einem kreativen impetus reis zu
sagen
travaglio bearbeitet nie das heißt fast
kraft euch nie in der arbeit dieses
monotone leben zwischen metro und otto
dass auch quasi die wünsche und die
träume aufsaugt wie herbert marcuse das
beschreibt und dass man dann gar nicht
mehr sein eigenes leben lebt und ein
fremd bestimmtes leben das über den
produktions apparat gesteuert wird hier
könnte man ja auch ein bisschen an
setzen und sagen es ist nicht der konsum
also hier eine kapitalismuskritik
sondern es ist das in die situationisten
diese der ansprechen der hatten die sehr
schöne vorstellung man müsse den
kapitalismus widerstand entgegensetzen
indem wir unser eigenes leben unsere
eigene situation sozusagen zu einem
kunstwerk machen
ja das war so eine wesentliche
konzeptidee dieser dieser dieser
situation ist
ich habe dafür große sympathien ich
glaube nur das ist ein sehr hoher
anspruch ist also ich glaube auch nicht
dass jeder mensch unbedingt sein leben
zum kunstwerk machen muss ich glaube
auch nicht dass jeder mensch unbedingt
kreativ sein muss wir laufen gefahr ein
bisschen die menschen zu überfordern
weil wir von solchen ansprüchen
rausgehen aber auf der anderen seite
wenn sie sehen dass natürlich diese
kreativität die dynamik dass man sich
selbst als ich ag verkauft auch wenn man
eben
vielleicht niedrigeren job in einem in
ein prekariat drinsteckt
arbeitstechnisch nimm dein schicksal in
die hand werde kreativ bei google
arbeitet man kreativen umfeld und die
animieren sollen um dann eben kreativ zu
sein um den arbeitsplatz gar nicht mehr
zu verlassen
die campus idee der großen heimischen
firmen wo man eigentlich gar nicht mehr
vom arbeitsplatz weg geht und sogar noch
beim squash spielen am abend mit den
arbeitskollegen kreativ ist das ist doch
schon eine forderung die pervertiert ein
bisschen wieder auftrag von dem was die
68er oder die vor 68er gewollt haben
das stimmt dass er ja auch so also ich
glaube dass diese ideen der kreativen
klasse von der nada auch spricht die
jetzt so wird die arbeit völlig neu
erfindet nicht und wo er arbeit und
freizeit alles ineinander übergeht
diese idee halte zum teil auch für
ideologisch ja also das ist zum teil
natürlich schon wenn sie wollen eine
ideologie einer bestimmten form von
kreativwirtschaft dem entstanden ist die
stichworte haben sie gedacht auch google
silicon valley und so weiter ich glaube
nicht dass dieses modell der kreativ
klasse ein modell für eine es ja ein
modell für jedermann
ich glaub da steckt dann versprechen von
von autonomie drin von selbstbestimmung
dass sehr viele menschen schlicht und
einfach überfordert
also wir sehen das sagen die idee auch
der ich-ag nicht dass es eine schöne
vorstellung hat ich bin unternehmer
jeder mensch sollte sein eigener
unternehmer sein möglichst unabhängig
sein sich freimachen
ja aber für viele menschen ist das so
viel
ja ich denke wir laufen gefahr dass wir
die menschen also die menschen
überfordern
nicht jeder mensch
will autonom arbeiten und ich glaube
auch nicht dass wir von jedem menschen
verlangen sollten autonom zu arbeiten
ein unternehmer zu sein eine ich ag zu
bilden sondern für viele menschen ist
ein job in einem abhängigen
arbeitsverhältnis und wo sie eben nicht
oder nur begrenzt autonom entscheiden
müssen genau das richtige und er ist er
nicht was schlechter ansonsten klar es
würde dann gerne auf dieses
sicherheitsbedürfnis noch zu sprechen
kommen
aber vielleicht wenn wir ein bisschen
bei den kreativen bleibt ebenso als
gesellschaftliche speerspitze die
natürlich in der kreativwirtschaft immer
das problem besteht der selbstausbeutung
dass man sagt weil ich ja eben eine
interessante sinnstiftende arbeit habe
nämlich in kauf dass sich unterbezahlt
bin dass ich gar nicht bezahlt bin es
gibt viele kreativ firmen die unter
vollbeschäftigung konkurs gehen weil sie
einfach nichts verdienen damit was sie
machen und trotzdem werden sie als als
wichtige vorreiter gelesen also das
problem dass selbstausbeutung besteht ja
das kann ich aus eigener erfahrung sagen
nicht dass ich aber auch selbst lange
genug als freiheit gearbeitet
das ist ein problem ist nicht das
einzige problem ich glaube dass mit
dieser form von arbeit fehle schlicht
und ergreifend auch nicht zurechtkommen
dass wir mit dieser mit dieser
unsicherheit nicht zurechtkommen damit
dieser form von arbeit verbunden wird
und um diese menschen müssen uns eben
auch kümmern denke ich also um die
kreativen ja also für die kreativen aber
auch für die die
nicht so kreativ sein können und für
diese art von arbeit eben nicht das
richtige ist ist jetzt dieser wunsch
nach der guten arbeit nach der besseren
arbeit diese art von vielleicht wunsch
nach einer ist nicht zu extremen
rahmenbedingungen setzen wie bei google
oder bei roche und novartis oder so
sondern dass man sagt man kann ja auch
schmutz und dadurch dass man fließen der
arbeitszeiten auch für kassiererinnen
kinderbetreuung also sind das die die
wünsche ihnen vorschreiben
also ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig dass
wir arbeit nicht auf die reine tätigkeit
reduzieren sondern arbeite es mehr ist
die reine tätigkeit arbeit ist komplexer
also die tätigkeit einer
supermarktkassiererin dass sie waren
über diese scanner schiebt die mag jetzt
für viele unbefriedigend oder entfremdet
seien aber die ihre arbeit besteht eben
nicht nur daraus ja was andere besteht
aus vielen anderen dingen ja die arbeit
besteht aber sie haben kollegen fällen
aus kommunikation mit anderen aus ganz
vielen dingen die die arbeitsbedingungen
beeinflusst und dazu gehört eben auch ja
beispielsweise wie viel freiheit habe
ich in der arbeit aus meiner sicht ist
eine wichtige frage der wird in zukunft
stellen müssen nicht so sehr wie
befreien wir die menschen von der arbeit
sondern wir schaffen wir mehr freiheit
in der arbeit also mehr flexibilität ist
zb der supermarkt rasieren ermöglicht
mehr zeit mit ihren kindern zu
verbringen oder auch mal ganz andere
dinge zu tun vielleicht ja immer auch
kreative dinge zu tun neben ihrer
eigentlichen tätigkeit aber das
stichwort ist schon partizipation also
das heißt dieses klassische das ist
marxistische vorstellung der entfremdung
dass man die anti kapitalistisch
kritisch
man geht in diesen innerhalb des
kapitalistischen systems
ja wobei ich glaube dass wir sehen uns
natürlich dass der kapitalismus auch
gute arbeit hervor bringt ja also es ist
ein irrtum der kapitalismuskritischen
linken zu denken dass im kapitalismus
keine gute arbeit möglich ist also der
kapitalismus bringt auch gute arbeit
hervor
und ich bin sehr dafür dass wir wenn wir
überarbeiten und versuchen die arbeit
konkret in den blick zu nehmen und uns
nicht die sicht verstellen lassen von
einem fahrschein kapitalismuskritik ja
also wir müssen es einfach konkret
ansehen was arbeit für menschen bedeutet
ob innerhalb des kapitalismus oder nicht
aber das heißt können wir das schaffen
wenn wir alles zu arbeit erklären was
nicht nichts tun ist also das heißt
beziehungsarbeit alles ist arbeit
ich glaube nicht dass jemand der sünden
ist ich glaube nicht dass alles arbeit
ist aber ich glaube wir könnten zb
arbeit so neu definieren dass wir sagen
arbeit ist jede form von tätigkeiten mit
regelmäßigen verpflichtungen verbunden
ist zum beispiel also wenn ich meine
meine kranken eltern pflegen muss zum
beispiel dann habe ich eine regelmäßige
verpflichtung und das aus meiner sicht
arbeit die wir auch als arbeit in der
gesellschaft bewerten sollten
aber wenn jemand sagen wir mal sich im
fitnessstudio jeden tag abgewählt dann
strengt dass sich zwar an aber es ist
aus meiner sicht meiner definition
jedenfalls keine arbeit werde nicht dazu
verpflichtet ist nicht jetzt durch die
verpflichtung zur arbeit kommen
natürlich gesundheitliche fragen auch
also arbeit macht in vielen fällen krank
in japan gibt es dieses diesem begriff
des karoshi also so dass man durch
überarbeitung aus pflichtbewusstsein 80
stunden
über 200 stunden überzeit im monat als
normal empfindet und dann irgendwo
plötzlich mit 41 an herzversagen stirbt
dass diese art von krankmachern bernard
dead men walking ist ein buchtitel also
dass das wir dass wir alles
überarbeitete arbeitstiere sind in
dieser situation dann müssen wir doch
auch aufpassen dass wir diese art von
übertreibung reduzieren
absolut börnert problematik sehr ernst
ich kenne aber auch selbst im
persönlichen bekanntenkreis fälle von
menschen mit burnout
nun muss man sehen arbeit kann krank
machen das richtig aber auch nicht
arbeit kann krank machen
beim burnout ist es eben so dass es
immer rein theorien um ein
missverhältnis geht ja ein
missverhältnis zwischen der arbeit und
der person zb durch konstante
überforderung also dass er konstant
überfordert das weiß ich ja also ich
glaube wir sind nicht eine konstante
überfordert wir haben vielleicht alle
stress das schon aber stress ist nicht
burnout stress ist faktoren eine rolle
spielt bei bernhard aber warum es bei
burnout geht und was sehr ernst zu
nehmen ist diese gefahr einer
permanenten überforderung die dem
subjekt sodass dann überhaupt keinen
spielraum lässt ja also das gefühl ich
bin in einer situation die mir einfach
über den kopf wächst in einem job der
mir über den kopf wächst und
gleichzeitig aber womöglich auch noch
eine disposition der mich selbst ein
bisschen anfälle gemacht dafür
für solche menschen kann es ja
gefährlich werden
und da müssen wir uns kümmern aber dass
wir schon in einem extremen clinton
stecken dass wir sagen eigentlich arbeit
ist teil meiner sozialen identität das
heißt ich stelle diese soziale konstrukt
über meinen individuellen bedürfnissen
und das heißt ich verzichte auf etwas
und dieses system
für die für das kollektiv macht mich
krank und kaputt weil ich diese grenze
zwischen mir selbst und der der gruppe
nichtig ziehen kann also zunächst mal
denke dass jeder auch bis zum gewissen
grade eben wie gesagt für sich selbst
verantwortlich ist
also muss als individuum schon noch
irgendwann erkennen wann es mir zu viel
wird nicht wir wissen zb aus der burnout
forschung erst dritter beantworten nicht
beim menschen auf jetzt den besonders
unbefriedigenden jobs sind und jetzt auf
ein unter viel stress leiden sondern im
gegenteil nicht dass er das so oft
besonders engagierte menschen in jobs
die hohes engagement fordern nicht dass
er ursprünglich kommt die burnout
problematik von lehrern zum beispiel von
ärzten von krankenschwestern also
menschen die sehr engagierte jobs
ausüben und dann ausbrennen weil sie
merken dass es sozusagen gingen im hafen
mit ihrem engagement und ich bin sehr
dafür dass man in der diskussion genau
differenziert also nicht jeder der an
stress hat weil er 50 e-mails abarbeiten
muss ist auch nur irgendwie burnout
gefährdet sodann da gibt es eben noch
andere faktoren die eine rolle spielen
und das ist im freundlichen die
überforderung von gesprochen habe die
überforderung
jetzt wird es doch noch einmal auf das
grundeinkommen dann zu sprechen kommen
weil offensichtlich eine der wichtigsten
faktoren um arbeiten zu gehen als erstes
nicht das geld kommt in umfragen sondern
die sicherheit also eben ein gewisser zu
sein in einer konstellation die eigene
sicherheit gibt soziale
diese sicherheit die schwindet zunehmend
weil die traditionellen berufe gefährdet
sind laut einer oxford studie werden von
den 700 bekannten berufsgattungen 47%
weggewischt werden in den nächsten 20
jahren sicher es wird neue geben es wird
andere geben aber trotzdem sicherheit
ist eine scheinsicherheit heute diese
karriere identität dass man ihn einmal
firma von der lehre bis zu bis zur
pensionierung arbeit all das wissen wir
das sind tempi passati und jetzt der
versuch sicherheit zu schaffen sich
unersetzbar zu machen präsent zu sein
mitzugehen ein kollektiv das wird
natürlich ausgenutzt vom system aber es
gibt keine sicherheit die zurück
geschenkt wird
ich glaube sagt zentral wichtiger punkt
denke wir müssen es menschen
beispielsweise einfacher machen
unbefriedigende jobs aufzugeben
etwas anderes zu machen das tun heute
viele nicht genau aus dem grund weil sie
die unsicherheit führt aber müsste da
nicht das staats als letzter der
sicherheit einspringen
ich glaube der staat aber auch der
unternehmer selbst also liegt das im
sinne der unternehmer ich glaube dass es
absolut im sinne im interesse
unternehmer liegt ihren mitarbeitern
mehr sicherheit zu geben
also wir wissen heute dass finanzielle
anreize alleine nicht mehr genügen
sondern es geht eher darum dass der
mitarbeiter mit ihrer arbeit und damit
letztlich auch mit dem unternehmen für
das er tätig sind identifizieren und was
hat es mit sicherheit zu tun ja also ich
kann nur loyal gegenüber einem leeren u
loyal gegenüber einem roten unternehmen
sein dass mir eben ein gewisses maß an
sicherheit bietet und deshalb glaube ich
es mit dem interesse von von von
nehmen sich darüber auch gedanken zu
machen aber in einer globalisierten welt
wo der lokalisiert wird wohl jobs
reduziert werden wo es permanent zu
systemänderung kommt nur schon die
verunsicherung die ein neues
computerprogramm ein system kreiert das
sind doch alles verunsicherung faktoren
die einen sagen in der kreativität in
der dynamik in der partizipation auch
hemmen
das stimmt ich glaube nur wir sollten
uns hüten für eine branche ein
kapitalismus der globalisierung ist
kritiken zum arbeit geht also ich glaube
dass viele probleme der arbeit werden
nicht einfach durch den kapitalismus
oder durch die cup durch die
globalisierung geschaffen sondern ganz
konkret durch management ja durch
bestimmte entscheidungen in unternehmen
also letzten endes wenn sie so wollen
auch durch kompetenz oder inkompetenz
von von von vom management von von
führungskräften ja also wenn bin sehr
dafür dass wir die menschen auch die
manager dann nicht aus der verantwortung
nehmen nicht also wir gewöhnen uns immer
mehr daran zu denken dass der markt oder
der kapitalismus sei an allem schuld und
das ist oft auch für manager sehr
angenehm weil sie eine mögliche eigene
verantwortung auf diese weise abzulegen
aber ich denke aber dass konkret ja und
und die aufgabe von guten management für
gute arbeit zu sorgen im ärgern und
unternehmern und das heißt eben auch
sicherheit zu schaffen für die eigenen
mitarbeiter letztlich weil es in ihrem
ärgern ärgern und interesse des
unternehmens ist es zu tun
es gibt es in dieser hierarchie der
wichtigen punkte weil deswegen wir
arbeiten offensichtlich eben also die
sicherheit da kommt das geld und an
dritter stelle relativ schnell
offensichtlich dass spaß und spaß
offensichtlich da reagiert die
wirtschaft so dynamisch also dass man
sagt man man bietet spaß an der arbeit
eben auch zur selbstoptimierung
unterstützung der mitarbeiter und der
spaß den könnte man tun nun doch einfach
verlagern weg von der arbeit in andere
bereiche also ich meine spaß sitzen
nicht in einem positiven sinn sondern
freude
da ist doch dann die kultur und also
wenn ihr beispielsweise vorträge bei
unternehmen halte sie ab und zu tun ist
das immer wieder ein wichtiger
diskussionspunkt unter bemerke ich
gerade das ja auch etwas zu ändern
beginnt bei den unternehmen dass er
nämlich erkennen es genügt natürlich
nicht den mitarbeitern eine kletterwand
hin zu stellen oder einen einen
kickertisch tischfußball um die
mitarbeiter bei laune zu halten
das wird von den mitarbeitern auch
durchschaut und die konsequenz ist dann
hofft dass niemand die kletterwand nutzt
als stiller protest oder weisen immer
traut bis zu einem jahr weil nämlich das
klima im unternehmerleben solches dass
es in wirklichkeit natürlich nicht gern
gesehen werden
also wir sollten nicht der illusion
erlegen
man könnte der unternehmen so eine art
vergnügungsparks verwandeln also da ist
es nicht das worum es geht denke arbeit
besteht auch nicht nur aus spaß spaß ist
wichtiger faktor keine frage aber selbst
ich in meinem job gehabt keineswegs den
ganzen tag spaß ja also zu meinem job
gehören ganz viele dinge dem
wie man versichert dafür überhaupt
keinen spaß machen und so hier
wahrscheinlich auch ich hoffe es nicht
zur jetzigen moment zu sein
das deckenlicht aber wir werden
sicherlich im laufe der woche ist ein
paar stunden absolut keinen spaß gehabt
habe mit dem job und trotzdem aber davon
überzeugt sein dass der job für sie der
richtige ist und mir geht sie hin und
ich glaube vielen anderen menschen auch
also die vorstellung ich musste jeden
tag von 8 bis 17 uhr da wir lange
gearbeitet wie lange ich spaß haben
ihr macht diese unterscheidung nicht so
ja also ich wenn sie so wollen in einer
gewissen weise habe die immer ich habe
da auch wenn sie so wollen im urlaub das
hat aber damit zu tun natürlich dass
meine spezielle form von tätigkeit kann
ich natürlich überall ausüben nicht also
kann auch in der u bahn sitzen und lesen
zum beispiel viele andere menschen
anderen jobs können das natürlich nicht
also das ist schon eine besonderheit
ich möchte von vom spaß und vor der
unterhaltung der freude der sinnvollen
existenz in eine kategorie der
gesellschaft springen die nicht arbeitet
nämlich die rentner die pensioniert und
ich habe den eindruck dass die ja gar
nicht so unglücklich sind wenn ich sie
ältere menschen im zug sei
ausfahrten machen wir sind in museen den
theater und opernhäuser und sehe doch
durch als in einer sehr zufriedenen
existenz drin sind weil sie sich auch
vermutlich und das zeigt eine studie in
der schweiz die gemacht wurde weil es
nicht mehr so ums geld geht weil es auch
meine zufriedenheit geht mit dem was
erreicht wurde und einem
selbstgenügsamkeit auf einem gewissen
grade die die älteren menschen zu den
glücklichsten in der gesellschaft macht
ja weil sie nicht mehr arbeiten müssen
also da sind wir wieder in der alten
moralischen geschichte das heißt also
man darf am sonntag alles tun weil man
viel gearbeitet hat unter unter der
woche also ich habe immer wieder erhält
darin mit den älteren menschen geredet
und da habe ich von filmen allerdings
auch gehört das widerspricht dem was sie
sagen aber nicht unbedingt dass ihre
arbeit vermissen
ja also erinnern wir ganz berührende
gespräche mit weit über 80 jährigen
menschen die sonne wie schön wäre es
wenn ich jetzt noch an der schule
unterrichten könnten der unterrichtet
haben mir fehlt das mir geht das ab ich
glaube aber das ist nicht unbedingt ein
widerspruch
also sicherlich müssen ältere menschen
jedenfalls aus den früheren generationen
und das wird sich jetzt ändern mit dem
künftigen generationen
da werden die leute arbeiten müssen
wahrscheinlich aber die die es nicht
mehr müssen empfinden es wohl als
erleichterung
du hast eben nicht wir müssen sonder
jetzt nur mehr tun wenn es immer neben
freude macht ja das heißt es könnte für
uns alle eine art von avantgarde seien
gesellschaftlich umzuschauen diese
bevölkerungsgruppe ist sehr interessant
wenn wir in die zukunft der arbeit
schauen
unbedingt also ich finde die unternehmen
müssen zum beispiel auf viel mehr tun um
ältere menschen genau solche angebote zu
machen also eine nach angebote zu machen
eben eben nicht fulltime jahr sondern
haben
vielleicht nur für ein paar stunden pro
woche einfach auch weil es spaß macht ja
ihre erfahrung zur verfügung stellen
und ich sehe das ganz genauso ich glaube
dass wir von den von ihnen von dem alten
da ganz viel ganz viel lernen können
aber eben glaube auch wir können eben
auch von ihnen lernen was arbeit für
leben bedeutet nämlich schon ganz schön
viel auch wenn man nicht mehr dazu
gezwungen ist zu arbeiten
ganz zum schluss zwei kleine fragen dass
eine haben sie nie sehnsucht nach mehr
zeit
cello zu spielen rosen zu züchten in
ihrem vortrag zu liegen
wenn man sich bei hohe luft den
gedankenexperimente überlegt und das
finde ich schön
was würden sie tun und was würde ich tun
wenn wir uns plötzlich zwei stunden
geschenkt bekämen sie kämen von irgendwo
her angeflogen
was würden sie jetzt wehtun würde dann
dinge tun zu denen ich sonst nicht komme
und wo es mir leid tut das ist sonst
nicht dazu komme mehr freunde treffen ja
wir haben eine familie kümmern solche
dinge ja vielleicht auch schneller
spielen spielen sie ziel ich spiele
nicht schneller aber ich hab mal
überlegt keyboard zu lernen und das wir
nach wie vor ein traum für derzeit
natürlich nicht arbeite ich versuche
ihnen in zwei stunden zu schenken im
nachtrag unseres gesprächs revanche
vielen herzlichen dank
danke nach der arbeit ist vor der arbeit
nächste woche erwartet sie hier am
werktisch in der sternstunde philosophie
stephan klapproth
er spricht mit dem demenz pionieren
michael schmieder über die neue
volkskrankheit und darüber was mit uns
passiert wenn wir unser selbst verlieren
[Musik]